agent stone the doctor thinks your basic
Jim Carrey is going full Jim Carrey and
Sonic is an alien with human teeth for
some reason it's gotta go fast
the very first sonic the hedghog trailer
is here and I'm here to break down
everything we know about this blue
juvenile delinquent and I'm only calling
him that because when you google sonic
does the first thing that pops up what
now let's start with Jim Carrey because
let's be honest that's the main Pole of
this entire thing I mean I grew up a
Sonic fan I played every Sonic game I'm
a 90s kid but then you go ahead and add
Jim Carrey to the mix goodness gracious
our job is to security neutralize it see
what makes it tick say what you will
about the trailer and we'll get into
some of those weirder things in a moment
but this sounds like classic comedic 90s
Jim Carrey how excited are you to be a
part of this film and did you ever play
Sonic growing up like I did yeah I did I
did stumble on it a couple of times I
was never a big video game guy but now
obviously I'm gonna lie and say I am
yeah you loved it you grew up with it
now he's playing the villain of the
Sonic games dr. Robotnik sometimes known
as Eggman for some reason in the game
he's a mad scientist who takes animals
and turns them into robots and he's bald
and he wears goggles and he has a
massive red moustache that's not what we
see here at first however at the end of
the trailer we get that glimpse of the
fully formed Robotnik while it's not
clear in the trailer the press release I
got in my inbox this morning for
Paramount confirms that this will be an
origin story of dr. Robotnik so this is
definitely in the tail end of the movie
okay let's get to the even weirder stuff
Sonic has human teeth human teeth why I
don't know and apparently is an alien
just something I never thought about
before the press release says he's
following the complexities of life on
Earth with his new human best friend
who's played by James Marcin okay now I
want to answer this basically it looks
like I'm gonna have to save your planet
anyway we get our first look at Sonic
walking and talking and he's got a
little bit of a detective Pikachu thing
going on take a look at this meow
put down the stapler or I will
electrocute you
now he's voiced by Ben Schwartz who's a
comedian known for Parks and Rec we love
Ben Schwartz and Ben Schwartz loves
Sonic check out what he had to say at
CinemaCon
if I was a kid I would have watch this
movie in a second and been so excited so
it got me really really excited and the
way that I see him is like he's this
childish like excited kid that just is
like he's funny his attitude if in the
video game I know there's a nerdy
references but like he wagged his finger
he stomps if you take too long so I
tried to bring all that comedy aspect to
it and bring like the energy and
excitement to it and then you have Jim
Carrey now some of the other Easter egg
things going on in this trailer we got
to talk about the city or the town that
they're in is called green hills now
Green Hill Zone is the first level of
the game so I love that I love that
callback Paramount logo when we're going
in it has the coins and he does that
little power spin thingy at one point
you know pretty get all charged up and
then the trailer has this line every
hero has a Genesis I love that who wrote
that you deserve a raise because that's
the most clever call out to Sega Genesis
which is of course
Sonic's console Sonic's home what did
you guys think of a Sonic trailer did
you hate it I for one have decided to
stand because and I know I keep saying
this Jim Carrey being Jim Carrey I love
it so much
now sonic opens November 8th 2019 wait
what November 8th oh my god anyway I'll
keep you guys updated on all things
Sonic the Hedgehog and all things Jim
Carrey cuz of course I will I'm Ash
Carlson and I'll see you guys next time
[Music]